so they weren't deliberating for very
long just a few hours or so right
exactly the really case it was we got
around to the idea of did apple make
these changes to to kill their
competitor or to improve the product
apple argued for the last couple weeks
that they did this to improve security
that the record companies they dealt
with for itunes were requiring them to
make these changes because of concerns
over hackers you had the plaintiff
saying the changes that apple was making
were like a candy bar an addictive candy
bar and customers just had to keep
coming back but here it seems that the
jury quickly decided that apple didn't
do anything wrong what do you make of
how quickly this verdict was returned
yeah it was they were in court for a
couple weeks and uh the plaintiffs
lawyers even lost some of their
plaintiffs at some point because of
various reasons and it was it was a
complicated case that they were trying
to make this idea that these changes
were made um to hurt a competitor that a
lot of people weren't even really that
familiar with it's interesting this is a
case that dates back like 10 years what
are the real implications for for apple
today well one of the big the big issues
was going to be how much if they were
found uh if they were found guilty would
be liable and it was going to be upwards
of a billion dollars but really this was
also just a kind of a black guy for
apple they the plaintiff was able to get
a video deposition of the late founder
of apple steve jobs and that was
something the company really did not
want to be shown tell us more about that
video what did we see in that video what
did steve jobs have to say it was about
six months before he passed and uh he's
on the step position and he is thin
and you know talking hoarsely but he he
said almost 30 times he didn't really
remember this the this issue back in the
day but he also was defensive of the
company's position they were concerned
of hackers so how much does this
actually impact apple now i mean is it
still a black eye
right they won and the other issue is
the technology that we're talking about
from back then is no longer uh not being
used in new itunes uh songs all right
tim hang on we actually are joined on
the phone now by william mark i'm a san
diego anti-trust attorney william i know
you've been following this case very
closely so what do you make of the fact
that in just a few hours the jury has
come back saying apple did nothing wrong
uh there's an old adage about
litigation which is that
an appellant is often the party who made
things very complicated at trial
and sometimes
a jury is
obliged
to endure an overly long
needlessly complicated trial and at the
end
they have not been persuaded they might
have been bored and just didn't grasp
what it was the plaintiffs were trying
to say
do you think the plaintiffs had no case
here
no i think they actually had a good case
but what the antitrust laws require them
to state
clearly and compellingly
is that apple introduced this
revision to its software
not to improve its offerings or to offer
security but simply to make it
impossible for competitors to sell music
that could be carried on its platform
and that it did so to try to establish
and preserve a monopoly position
in its market which would be the sale of
music that can be played on these ipods
now i've been speaking with our
bloomberg news apple reporter tim
higgins i'll ask you the very same
question i asked him even though apple
has won here how does this reflect on
apple today and going forward is this
still a black eye on the company
or you're asking me i'm sorry
well i don't think this can i think this
is a victory for apple um but apple is
involved in a in a in another case the
ebook pricing case in which it was
uh uh found
a libel at trial in and this was in new
york for conspiring with the book
publishers to fix to fix and raise
prices for ebooks
and so i don't think apple is
has emerged as as
an altruist uh or
um
uh a competitor that does not engage in
antitrust abuses but but clearly it's
it's a good day for apple that that it
has not been found liable in this case
apple has also faced a series of patent
challenges from companies like samsung
you mentioned the e-book pricing trial
and even though that they they have won
today would you say there appears to be
something
wrong with the way that apple does
business from a legal perspective
that's a great question and i think it's
not just apple there appears to be
a distinct business culture in the
silicon valley and many silicon valley
companies somehow seem to think that
they're immune from
from the antitrust laws from ordinary
laws of business valuation
and from from other business precepts uh
and it's not just apple and even more
spectacularly there's there's the uber
company
and there's there was the employee
poaching case which in which involved
all of the the big companies in the
silicon valley or seemingly so
and so i think it's apple's conduct does
raise serious antitrust concerns and
other concerns as well and it seems to
be characteristic of a certain business
culture that we sometimes see in the
silicon valley
but what kind of recourse will there be
for actions if if indeed they are not
above board
well it depends on the particular
conduct but i think that the
department of justice and the state's
attorneys general
and private litigants have successfully
pursued apple for coordinating a
conspiracy to raise the prices of
e-books
and apple
has made
that they aggressively enforced their
most favored nation clauses to try to
raise prices of different products
and i think we've seen successful
actions challenging that
and the best remedy though is that
perhaps within apple
the the directors and officers of the
company will say we don't need this bad
publicity we don't want the expense of
all these different anti-trust actions
let's make sure that we're not
engaging in conduct
that that
appears to subvert competitive processes
and
that whose principal
uh purposes seem to be to undermine our
competitors not improve our offerings
and that's that's the hallmark of van i
trust
how much of this uh william is the
responsibility of tim cook a lot of
these cases
date back to the days when steve jobs
was in charge now that tim cook is in
charge do you expect things
to be done differently
yes
it seems to i think that
steve jobs was a he was an uh a
visionary
he he was an inspired designer he had uh
extraordinary
insight into how he anticipated markets
as no one else seemed to be able to do
but he also seemed to lack
an intuitive grasp
of what kinds of conduct would be
could be easily characterized as
blatantly
all anti-competitive one last question
for tim
one last question for tim higgins here
uh with me in the studio what's next tim
what are you watching
any other legal issues yeah we're going
to be watching watching the ebooks
definitely but this case is really a
really good example window into what
apple was like uh you know a decade ago
when they were the underdog these record
play these record companies were willing
to deal with apple because they were not
the behemoth that they are now and so
we're seeing kind of the evolution of
the company over time now now they are
the world's largest but back then they
were the underdog are you saying then
they're going to behave differently or
they already are behaving you're
starting to see that with tim cook he's
being more open
in his communication style than steve
jobs was